[screaming]
[bear roars]
Really glad that the
wild is not like that,
because I would be dead
a thousand times over.
My name is Laura Zerra.
I'm a survival specialist,
and I've been practicing and
teaching wilderness survival
for over 17 years.
I participated in five seasons
of the Discovery show "Naked and Afraid."
Today, I'll be looking at
wilderness survival scenes
in movies and judging how real they are.
[yelling]
Unexpected falls and falls in general
are actually one of the
biggest ways people die
when they're in the backcountry.
It doesn't always have to be a cliff face,
it can just be a steep slope.
It's definitely something to look out for.
As far as climbing into a
horse as a means of survival,
it would totally work.
The length of time it would
work for is going to be limited,
and I think the biggest
mistake that he did
was not taking that gut
pile and cuddling it,
because there's so much bacteria in guts
that continue to stay
alive and produce heat
once the animal's already dead.
So the guts are really where the heat is.
There are certain kinds
of clothing, like wool,
that will still keep you
warm and add some heat,
even if they're wet.
I think being naked,
you're already dealing with
losing heat through being wet
and any gusts that are
getting in through that hole,
so it seems a little risky
to take your clothes off
if you don't have to.
As he's pulling that gut pile out,
he realizes it's warm.
And why would you not have it at least
kind of sealing up the
door that you're in?
I would give this clip a 7.
I think that it's pretty smart.
It takes a lot of guts,
no pun intended, pun intended,
to be able to do something like this.
I brought with me only
the bare essentials.
A knife, roll of duct tape,
in case I need to fashion a shelter.
I actually think someone
on "Naked and Afraid"
once brought a roll of duct
tape as their survival item.
And they're supposed to
be professionals, so.
And take a look at this.
I tented my pants.
I've made myself a nice
pants-tent shelter.
I love that clip.
I think it's clearly ridiculous.
And yet, at the same time,
he probably did better
than a lot of people in
his situation would do.
He was looking at what he had
and trying to figure out how
he could creatively use it.
Now, I think taking your clothes off,
like, your clothes are already a shelter,
they're already like your
first form of shelter.
So taking them off to
make a secondary shelter
probably isn't gonna be great.
But it's better than
running around in circles
until you're completely
dehydrated and exhausted.
Michael: Those are
nature's best mushrooms!
These little buggers
are damn tasty as well.
Eating the mushrooms is a terrible idea.
Even when mushrooms are edible,
a lot of them in the
wild you have to cook.
So, yeah, he would have died pretty quick
[laughs] in that situation.
If it wasn't for the mushrooms,
I would have given Michael's
survival skills a 4,
because he's at least thinking
about what he needs to do
and trying to be creative about it.
And that's a great start.
[wolf growls]
[laughs] Well, he's in trouble.
But how many times do wolves
actually attack humans?
And the answer is almost never.
I think there's, like, a
couple documented cases
of that happening in North America.
And I see wolves pretty much
every single time I'm out in the woods.
Wolves are terrified of people.
If wolves wanted to hunt people,
people wouldn't go in the woods,
because they're amazingly
effective predators.
They outmatch us on every physical front.
They just don't have any interest.
We don't look like food.
If you did run into a
extremely desperate wolf
who was thinking about the possibility
that you might be a food source,
then you want to make yourself
look as big as possible.
Put your arms up, start yelling,
make some noise, kick some rocks at it.
Wolves can run over 30 miles an hour,
so running is going to do nothing.
[glass shatters]
I don't know who else has
ever used electric tape,
but it's not this rigid stuff.
That stuff's just going to end up
breaking off further
probably before it penetrates
the wolf's really thick fur and hide.
And I could see him getting
more hurt from doing that
than any benefit it would serve.
Creative. Again, really like his mindset.
He's kind of just willing to do whatever
and be creative to survive.
I would give this clip a 1,
because you're already starting
on really false pretenses.
I don't like when this myth
of wolves being man-eaters,
man-hunters is perpetuated.
[trap snaps]
Ah!
Somebody help me!
I'm really super focused at this moment
on what he used for a mechanism
to get that much force on that trap,
because that was
impressively fast and strong.
There's a lot that goes into
making a trap like that.
Sharpening a bunch of stakes
and setting them into another log,
I mean, we're talking hours.
And then just setting the trap
and coming up with the right tension
on the mechanism that
you're using to trigger it,
and then finding a place to put it.
A trap only works if you
have someone walk into it.
So the way you get around that
is either to set a lot of traps,
which would take a lot of time,
or by funneling the movement in.
So it's not something you
can just do on the fly
and expect to work.
[yells]
Don't push it.
Camouflage is absolutely
useful in survival,
whether it's, you know, in a situation
where you're clearly
trying to run from someone,
or maybe you're just hunting.
He had, I think they were
hemlock branches on his back.
But unless he's hiding with
his back towards everyone,
it's not going to be useful,
because the idea is to break up the form
so that you don't look like a person.
And I could say the same
about his face camo.
Like, maybe do a better job of, like,
working with your face
to make it look less like
your eyes are standing
out, and your eyebrows.
I mean, his eyebrows
were so dominant still.
So creating some kind of
color scheme on his face
where his eyes and his
eyebrows were less dominant
would have done better than just, like,
smearing stuff everywhere.
I would give this a 5.
Realistically, I struggle with
the time invested in the trap.
Some really accurate portrayals
of survival skills in here.
The hand drill is amazing.
Like, spot on, totally would work.
I think the biggest problem I have
is when you're trying to forge,
it's really hard to get a temperature
that's high enough to forge metal
when you're using wood.
I think wood, a wood fire can burn
at about 900 or so degrees.
You need about 1,500
to start moving metal.
Otherwise, to get the metal that hot
seems really unlikely to me.
If I'm in a survival situation
and I don't have a knife,
I will use stone, all the time.
It's obviously ideal if
you have a steel knife,
but by adapting the
way that you do things,
a stone knife or stone tools
can actually accomplish the same tasks.
Dealing with metal requires
so many specific things
that stone's going to work
for whoever you need to kill
or whatever task you need to accomplish.
I basically just want a
knife that has an edge
that is going to be able to carve wood.
So for traps, for skinning animals,
having a smaller knife,
anything where you're carving
or doing fine, intricate work,
something smaller is going to be better.
I would give this clip
probably an 8 out of 10.
I think it was really
surprisingly accurate.
The one thing was the fire.
[screaming]
[bear growls]
Ugh, another example
of animals just being out to get you
in the most dramatic fashion.
Really glad that the
wild is not like that,
because I would be dead
a thousand times over.
Grizzly attacks are definitely more common
than wolf attacks, and it can happen.
Usually a grizzly is attacking
in a defensive situation.
Either you surprised it,
there's a mother-and-cub situation.
Basically, you got too close,
and it wants to get you away.
It's not going to hunt you
and consume you, per se,
it's just trying to get you on the ground
so you're not moving,
and then it's going to
take off and run away.
Normally I think it would be
more a case of that happening
when it was a single person walking along
versus, like, a whole group around fire,
but it can happen.
[screaming]
[bear growls]
Stay back!
Depending on where the bear is,
a lot of times they're
pretty used to fire.
If they're coming into camp
and they're used to stealing food,
I have a hard time thinking
that if you have a log
that's burning with embers at the end
and you're shoving it into a bear's eye,
that it's not going to at least
slow him down a little bit.
I wouldn't just wave it in his face.
I think that's where they
messed up a little bit.
And everyone else, like,
throw some stuff at him.
They didn't even make contact.
If they're gonna stay
and fight, then fight.
If it was a situation
where you surprise the bear
and the bear starts attacking
and it's just trying to get away from you,
then that's when you want to play dead.
Stop moving. Don't move
until the bear is long gone.
Try to be in areas where
you can see further than,
you know, 20 feet, and carry bear spray.
I would give this scene a 1.
Not saying it doesn't happen,
but this was very unrealistic,
and the way they responded
was just like, come on.
There's better things
you guys could've done.
Ben?!
[yells]
First of all, is that Kate Winslet?
Which is just funny that she didn't, like,
find a door this time to float on.
There's a lot of things I'm
not buying in this clip.
She basically falls through
a perfect hole of ice.
I really struggle with the fact
that the second she hits the water,
she's just peacefully passed out.
There's no struggle.
There's no hyperventilating.
Like, is she just, like,
one of those fainting goats
who comes into a bad situation
and is no longer conscious?
That's what it felt like watching this.
She was immediately just out.
And it can happen.
You can pass out, and
you can hyperventilate,
breathe water, whatever, but
it happened so soon.
How did he find her in there?
It's obviously deep water,
and she apparently just is comprised
of mostly fat underneath her clothes,
because she was so buoyant.
It seemed very improbable for someone
to just float back to the surface
and not float away to
the sides of the hole
and be able to be grabbed.
He had to run so far to get to that hole.
And her body is just right there.
It's a little too convenient
for me to be OK with.
When he was pulling her
body out of the ice,
it was good that at least his
body was kind of spread out.
His body weight wasn't
just centered on the edge.
I would rate this clip
probably a 1.
I just don't understand any of it.
This is -- this is Vaccinium uliginosum?
So this is, um.
If I'm trying to learn an area,
I will absolutely bring some kind of book
to help me identify what I'm looking at.
Whether it be plants, animal
tracks, things like that,
it's super useful to learn.
It's also very limited.
You might get one picture
at one time of the year of a plant,
so to just have one resource
and then use it to consume something
that could potentially kill you,
in my opinion, isn't a great idea.
Out in the wild, you just
have to be really careful.
You are not going to
be consuming something
that you're not 100%
certain of its identity.
It's a really bad idea.
And, furthermore,
you're probably not
getting that many calories.
It's not going to be the
matter between life or death.
You can't really exist off
of the few meager calories
you're going to get from
a lot of plant foods.
So to run the risk of eating it,
not knowing 100%,
it's like a risk-versus-reward thing,
and it loses out every time.
You really can get into
trouble very quickly,
and there are certain things you can do
that will really increase that.
There's very few things
you can actually control,
but what you put in your
body is one of those.
So don't mess around with anything
that you can't identify 100%.
I would give this clip a 10.
Honestly, it's definitely something
that can and did happen.
Hannah: Can you swim?
[fire crackling]
This is a remarkably unsmoky fire.
Wildfires can travel really fast.
They can basically travel
as fast as the wind.
That being said,
it really seemed to be
traveling on the ground a lot,
and it didn't look like
there was any brush
there to catch on fire.
But it can happen. And
fires are super scary,
and being caught in one
would be absolutely terrible.
If you can, getting upwind of that fire,
trying to figure out the
direction it's moving in
and kind of move perpendicular to it
and get out of the path of it,
because the smoke can take you out.
Anyone who's ever stood in campfire smoke,
you know what that's like.
A forest fire would clearly be way worse.
You know, carbon monoxide, carbon dioxide,
all these nasty things.
You basically just want to get
out of its path if you can.
Sometimes that's kind of impossible.
And there's unfortunately a lot of stories
where people have been caught
in situations like this
and didn't make it out,
even highly trained people.
Listen to me. Take a deep breath,
hold it, and lay back.
I've actually read about people
who've survived wildfires
by being in pools or bodies of water.
And kind of the key thing is
that you want it to be deep enough
that it's going to cover your whole body
and not just immediately get too hot.
The flames can actually pass
over the top of the water,
so if your body's sticking out,
it can definitely be a bad situation.
The problem with deep water would be
getting exhausted or just
passing out and drowning.
But in certain circumstances,
it could definitely work.
I think it really looked
like their only option,
and people have definitely
done it and survived.
[takes deep breath]
I think the one thing I
would have done differently
would be wetting an item of clothing.
And then when I did have
to come up and surface,
you have a wet piece of
clothing over your face,
so it's cooling down that air.
'Cause that air is going
to be super heated.
Like, that goes into your lungs,
and even if there's not smoke,
just the superhot air can
burn the inside of your lungs.
That cool cloth over your face
is going to not only protect your face
from any falling embers,
but it's going to cool down the air
and just keep your skin cool as well.
I would probably give this scene a 7.
There's a lot of things with the fire
I have trouble with, but they did try.
They put thought into it.
This could work.
It's better than nothing,
but there are ways it
could have been improved.
[ice cracks]
Irena, no!
Ice is funny.
So, you can't always tell
the thickness of ice.
You want it to be at least 4 inches
to support your body weight.
And there's a few factors
that make it more dangerous,
whether it's still or moving water,
where it is, if it has snow on top,
which can actually
insulate it like a blanket
and prevent it from becoming really thick.
If you look at ice, generally,
if it's clear, then
it's going to be thick,
but if it's kind of that milky color,
it means it's gone through
processes of thawing and freezing
and probably isn't that thick or safe.
And if you do have to go out on it,
you don't want to be running.
What you have is your entire body weight
coming down hard and fast
on one point that's small.
So if you had to cross
something, getting flat,
spreading your body weight out,
there's a million ways
they could have done it.
[ice cracking]
There's definitely a risk of wet clothing.
If they were to swim across
and everything got wet
and they couldn't start a fire,
they could be in a bad situation.
Being way back then, I think a lot of it
would have been wool clothing,
which actually will keep
you warm when it's wet.
It's not ideal to have it be wet,
you're not going to have as much
of the insulating properties,
but you'd still be OK if you were moving,
and they could just keep moving
until their body heat
dried their clothes out.
People die in a few minutes in cold water.
It's not from hypothermia.
It's from going into
that shock and drowning
or losing mobility in
their limbs and drowning.
I would give the accuracy of this a 1.
I think the biggest movie
myth in wilderness survival
is that it's always
something big and dramatic
that's coming and trying to get you.
And in real survival,
it's not like that.
It's the little things.
It's the hypothermia, it's dehydration,
but it's not as exciting
as a grizzly bear.
If you enjoyed this video,
click above to watch another.